hi this is preshtalwalker in this video
we're going to go over some solutions to
two classic puzzles about drawing lines
in the first puzzle you have nine
different dots that you need to connect
without lifting your pen and you have to
do it with at most four straight lines
and you can't retrace any of the lines
so this puzzle is very famous the trick
is you need to think outside of the box
so here's one way that you can connect
all the dots with four straight lines
in the second puzzle about connecting
the six boxes
the trick the very difficult part is
that
letter b will be difficult if you
connect it straight up and down it's
going to intersect something else
so the trick is you need to go around
the boxes c and a
this will allow you to connect the
remaining boxes
quite easily so here's one way you could
do it there of course many different
ways you can draw it
i hope you liked this video
please subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon for
exclusive rewards
catch me on my blog minor decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker
and you can get my books listed on my
website